[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's adam lefkow host of nba on tnt also
the left go show podcast bleach report
gaming's uh underrated on tbs so adam
lefko joining us here on the program is
he with us uh todd he sure is oh okay uh
hey lefko uh biggest storyline going
into the season is
oh man you caught me in a whirlwind
between ben simmons and kyrie irving uh
i feel like those are the two
nba 75th year anniversary that's the
biggest one but i think
what's gonna happen to these two guys
that are not currently playing right now
uh do the team even like him in terms of
ben simmons and in terms of kyrie irving
does the team even need him uh those are
the two questions uh that i'm kind of
thinking storyline was who would you
rather interview between those two
uh oh uh kyrie's going to take you to a
place that you have no idea where he's
going
um and i i'm someone that does find it
somewhat entertaining
ben it feels like a lot of angst a lot
of anger a lot of built up
just frustration
and i feel like it's going to be a lot
of no comments so at least i can have a
conversation with kyrie which one is
more salvageable
kyrie i think that
when we would always have these stats
last year for mba on tnt how is this
team with kyrie and durant but no harden
and how are they they were great
and so when you look at the depth of
this roster i totally forgot uh patty
mills i know but they got javon carter
too from phoenix they're very deep and
james harden played a lot of point guard
last year and so i think that this nets
team could start off really hot and then
three four months in possibly he gets
the vaccine and joins them with ben he
is literally working out in a hooded
sweatshirt with the sleeves cut off
wearing full pants to practice he's not
playing we are we are watching a hold in
instead of a hold out and i think that
this is just posturing for a possible
trade who had a great offseason
um
i think the fact that the bucks
re-signed a lot of guys
uh
they got continuity in a league of
constant change um
i i thought it was really well done for
boston to kind of move a bunch of their
pieces uh and retain their core and
still build around tatum
i think i would have said phoenix but
this deandre ayton not getting the max i
think
suddenly brings trouble in paradise uh
but i think also the lakers and and
specifically russell westbrook
to go from the washington wizards to the
lakers what an off-season for him like
really impressive what is the game plan
do you think for the lakers during the
regular season
so
that was the best part of the russell
westbrook move by the lakers in my
opinion is that lebron is now
and he has been for the last few years a
ceo that doesn't need to be in every
meeting and i think when you heard the
upset nature of him with jared dudley
leaving
he needed those generals to keep the
team motivated during the regular season
and i don't think anyone does that
better than russell westbrook we heard
it in houston where he was on the plane
and they're waiting for hardin and then
he goes to washington and all of a
sudden the team and bradley beal is
focused lebron now has his general his
everyday general to keep that team
motivated during the regular season uh
we saw last year like they're okay
going for the seven or eight seed if it
means you know resting lebron a little
bit
i think that they're gonna go for it all
this year i think that when you look at
the west i think the suns are great but
i think it's unlikely that they have a
similar run back to back it's just tough
to do that two years in a row so i think
they're kind of going up against utah to
try and win the regular season but i
think as long as they're in the top four
uh they're feeling good but i really
think westbrook now is that day-to-day
general of the team who's the most
overrated team
um
overrated
i think like i just said i would just
from having watched sports a long time
it's probably unlikely that phoenix and
atlanta do what they did again you know
those just seemed like big runs
motivated by a lot of
and there was so much opening in the
west with kawhi's injury and the lakers
injuries i just i think phoenix is
probably the team that people are
penciling into the finals that i i just
i would bet against them
who is underrated
i like the utah jazz
and
mainly because of conversations that we
have had before about yeah i get this
with the bucks in the regular season but
show me in the playoffs and then it
happened and this happened with the
raptors a few years ago
i'm not saying rudy gay is the guy the
missing piece that brings this all
together because that's just that's a
good thing that's i'm glad you didn't
okay yeah i i i but aren't you year
three into loving the utah jazz
i do love the union
um
i i think it was watching rudy gobert in
the olympics
and it was watching him get brought into
similar situations in the playoffs where
he's having to defend guards and he
actually did it um but look i've
melo olympic mello uh messed me up for a
number of years so i just
i have to imagine that
all of these years of of getting just
absolutely swept in the playoffs i don't
know man i'm a sucker for pain you know
and so i think the utah jazz are my tool
this season who's your finals pick
um all right i'll be i'll be even sicker
because if it happens i want credit i'll
put the jazz in there
um and i'm going to put the nets so
it'll be jazz versus nets
the the thing that i'm thinking about
tonight's game which is a matchup for
the eastern conference finals bucks nets
is
the one player the bucks didn't bring
back is pj tucker
and
i know it's weird to read that pj tucker
was a great defender against kevin
durant when kevin durant had like an
all-time game in games five and seven
um but
the reason he was so big is it meant
that giannis and middleton didn't have
to guard durant and so it changed up
their philosophies and i just i'm
looking at the team right now and all i
can think about is if i went to vegas
i'm putting my number one bet is
durana's mvp that's just
the way the season ended now he's got a
full healthy off-season there's no kyrie
so he's going to get credit for like
playing well without kyrie
i just don't know who stops him so i
would go jazz nets why is it i can't
release or cut that umbilical cord from
the golden state warriors
oh like steph curry's my number two pick
for envy yeah i had him mvp last year
and i
and you know klay thompson's the missing
ingredient they got young young players
they got some youth on there
uh i don't know if they have the magic
dust for one more run but i'm i'm kind
of holding on that they do
there are three teams that i really
really like but injuries are what
prevents me from picking them long-term
kawhi with the clippers uh jamal murray
with the nuggets and klay thompson with
the warriors all expected back a few
months into the season and if they were
there the entire time i just don't know
what i'm getting and so
i am so excited to watch
curry clay and draymond and and now with
all of this wisdom i was reading about
draymond yesterday and how you know he
used to be the guy that could talk to
the team and and talk about like
advanced mathematics when it comes to
nba and now all the young guys are
looking to him and i i love the fact
that we're gonna get super veteran clay
curry and draymond um i just without
clay they are a p short and i don't know
where we're gonna get in january it's
great to talk to you have fun tonight
and remember what did you have for
breakfast where are you going later
today
where is that shirt made why are you
wearing that sweater
it has seashells uh because you know
milwaukee is a beach town yeah yeah i
take the kids there we used to we used
to take the kids there for the summers
you know
it's you know it's just you know if i
can get a margarita on the beach
because i would say to the kids
milwaukee or disney world and they go
milwaukee
easy yes
remember your role is john stockton yeah
pass get the get the assist out get the
ball out quick that's that's your
rapid-fire question no you don't even
have to have a did john stockton ever
have a no-look pass
i just reveal that i'm not wearing you
don't have pants on do you
this is i would stand up and show you no
no no no okay no no no it's the best you
don't
yeah i don't want to see your left go
and your right co
[Laughter]
i haven't referred to it
[Laughter]
uh thank you bud
thank you
adam lefkow nba on tnt host and a man
who's not wearing pants at least in that
interview